ceremonies are a lesser known and lesser
utilized communication device um in
organizations today so back as far as
you can study human behavior there has
been ceremonies in some way and what we
did is we looked at the rites of passage
most even religions have some sort of
rite of passage ceremony what happens is
you could be single one moment you go
through a ten minute marriage ceremony
and suddenly you're married so this
moment this ceremony transforms you I am
no longer this time now that when you
graduate you go through a graduation
ceremony you know and there's these
moments about Mitzvah or Kingston era
where it's like I was once a young
person and now I'm an adult only
difference is like this small ceremony
happened to show transformation but that
ceremony does is it says I am no longer
this and I am now that especially when
an organization is leading really big
change they need these moments where
they pause and say we're not that
anymore and now we are now this one of
the great examples from the book that I
love is we covered when Steve Jobs was
leading the transition from mac os9 to
Mac OS 10 he just come back to Apple and
that was what they needed that's why
they bought next his company was to have
the next operating system in place and
the developers were so skeptical he even
did a talk called Apple's hierarchy of
skepticism because everyone was so
skeptical that they could actually do it
he had so much skepticism then he
started to get momentum and there was
this moment where he had this new dream
where he really wanted everybody
connected to a digital digital hub and
he was getting frustrated with the last
stragglers all these stragglers hadn't
made the decision to come on so there
was an opening scene at WWDC the big
Developers Conference where he actually
had a coffin under the stage this coffin
rises up from the stage smoke billows
out stained-glass slide up there he
walks out with an oversized block a
matte box of mac os9 and a red rose he
puts the box in the coffin shuts the lid
puts a rose on top and he eulogized the
death of mac os9
it's not a speech it's not a story it
was a ceremony he never talked about the
transition from mac os9
to Mac os10 ever again he was telling
them developers is done move on or it's
just done and it was a really important
ending so that they would all understand
that you know what I need to begin again
and that's what a ceremony
death there was another kind of
ceremonial thing he did because the
developers were so frustrated they
didn't believe that Apple was going to
stick with one single software strategy
because they'd been through a decade of
confusion and myths and starts and
multiple tries a ton operating system so
the WDC before the one he did the actual
funeral at mock funeral mmm
he had actually done a vow and he pulled
out an oversized peach a piece of
parchment paper out and he made a public
vow to the developer community that they
were gonna stick with a single software
strategy so it was very dramatic any
about you know help unfurled this piece
of parchment paper and made a vow and a
vow is like a wedding vow right it's a
covenant and a promise that's a ceremony
it's not a speech it's not a story it's
a ceremony so it was about endings and
beginnings and commitments and that's
what ceremonies doom
you